what we're going to do is think about
the graphs of marginal utility and total
utility curves
and so right over here i have a table
showing me the marginal utility i get
from getting tennis balls and so it says
look if i have no tennis balls and i'm
not able to play tennis so i'm pretty
happy when i get that first ball it
gives me a marginal utility of 100. now
you might say a hundred what sal and i
would say to you well that's the thing
about marginal utility we're using
fairly abstract units here we're not
speaking in terms of dollar or
opportunity cost we're just have this
abstract unit we could call it utility
units if we want but what really matters
is the relation between these values so
for example that second ball it's nice
now i can lose that first ball or i
don't have to chase that first ball
around as frequently but it's not as i
don't get as much incremental utility
that as i got from that first ball that
first of all allowed me to play tennis
now the second ball i was already
playing tennis now my tennis is just
going to be a little bit more pleasant
so the marginal utility one way to think
about it this is 80 and this is 100 the
marginal utility of that second ball is
eighty percent of what that first ball
is
now i promise that i would graph these
so let's get a graph out here
so there we go and let's start plotting
these and see what it looks like
well that first ball gave me a utility
of a hundred the second ball gives me a
utility of 80. third ball you see the
trend this is a downward sloping if this
was a line these are discrete values
here but if i cared about half of a
tennis ball or three-fourths of a tennis
ball then i could connect the dots here
as well
but you can see that it is a downward
sloping line if you were to connect the
dots so three balls utility of 60
if i have four balls it's a utility of
40.
five balls utility of
20. and once again when i get that fifth
ball yeah it's nice but now my pockets
are getting pretty full and i was all
it's hard to play tennis with those full
pockets by the time i get that sixth
ball i get no
marginal utility from that i'm i i don't
have a place to store it it's i don't
really i'm not really into it and then
that seventh ball i actually view it as
a negative it's one extra ball to worry
about no place to store it it's it's
taking up space in my life
and so if you were to connect the dots
we're talking about a discrete case but
oftentimes you could think about
something that's a little bit more
continuous or the quantity is more
granular if you said pounds of chocolate
or
or something like that
then you could imagine in general for a
marginal utility curve to be able to
connect these dots
and you see in this case it is downward
sloping so this is the marginal utility
the marginal utility curve notice that
it is slopes down
slopes
down and this you're generally going to
see this for any marginal utility curve
because the incremental benefit of that
next amount that next unit is seldom as
good as the benefit of getting it before
you get tired of the thing you start
running out of space you've already
consumed more than you need of it and
this is consistent with what we know
from the law of demand and the law of
demand every incremental amount of
quantity people like well i already have
some and this might not be the law of
demand is not talking about just an
individual it's talking about a market
but the market as a whole where is made
up of individuals and if each individual
is saying hey you know that that first
unit really matters to me but the next
unit it's nice but not as good so i'd
pay less for it and then the unit after
that it's nice so i might pay less for
it and so if you aggregate all those
individuals that's where that law of
demand comes from these are consistent
ideas and that's why the demand curve
you are also
it is sloping down price is usually on
this axis instead of utility and you
could imagine price as being a proxy for
utility and quantity of course is on
this axis right over here so this is
quantity of balls so that's our marginal
utility curve what about total utility
so
let me
have a table here that shows total
utility and total utility for marginal
utility is pretty straightforward
all you do is say okay well that first
ball when i have one ball my total
utility is the same as my marginal
utility and so
you're going to have that same starting
place
at when your consumption is just
beginning
but then your total utility from two
balls well i had a hundred utility units
from the first ball and then i get 80
more from that second ball so it's going
to be 180. so
for two balls my total utility is
180. all i'm doing is i just added that
to that now for three balls i add that
to that to that i take 180 and i add the
60 extra utility units i get for that
third ball and now i'm at 240. so that
third ball gives me gets me to
240 right over there
now the fourth ball once again i'm just
going to take 240 and add the
incremental utility of that fourth ball
the marginal utility of that fourth ball
that gets me to 280.
so that gets me to
280 which is right
over
let's see 20 30 20 40 60 80. so this is
right over there
now that fifth ball i'm just going to
take the 280 and then the marginal
utility of the fifth ball add 20 gets me
to 300.
fifth ball gets me to 300 which would be
right around
there
now the sixth ball gave me no
incremental no marginal utility so my
total utility when i have six balls
stays the same i'm in indifferent as to
whether i have five or six balls so the
sixth ball it is now flat right over
here and now the seventh ball i'm tired
of these tennis balls i'm being
overwhelmed by them i'm finding it
stressful and so it actually has a
negative marginal utility and so my
total utility if someone forced me to
have seven balls my total utility would
now go down by 20. and so my total
utility now would be
280 right over here and you could see
the marginal utilities here if you just
say look this is plus 80. this is plus
60. this is plus 40. this is plus 20.
this is plus zero and then this is minus
20. and so you see the numbers
right over
right over there
now
this tennis ball example this would be a
discrete case you you wouldn't have half
a tennis ball or
pi tennis balls or something like that
but if we want to speak in general terms
you could think about connecting the
dots if you had a more continuous
example
and your total utility curve might look
something
like this
now what's interesting is right when
you're beginning consumption you're
starting at the same place well that
makes sense your first unit yet marginal
utility that's going to be your total
utility and this is upward sloping as
long as you're getting some positive
marginal utility from each increment so
as long as my marginal utilities were
positive well this slow this this graph
is going to be increasing but notice
because the marginal utilities are
getting are decreasing right over here
the rate of increase for total utility
is decreasing the slope here is
decreasing you can view the marginal
utility as the slope of the total
utility curve
and then notice the total utility curve
has a maximum value it's starting to hit
a maximum value right over there when
the marginal utility curve is hitting
zero because beyond that point where at
least in this example we had negative
marginal utility and so when you add
that seventh unit well that's going to
make your total utility curve go down
and so you're going to have a negative
slope in this particular example